I think about all the time we [__] up
why we could have been yoked why after
like touring like comedy clubs where
you're just like in and out of hotels
and stuff I was still able to figure out
a rhythm and then I always think like
dude we could have loaded that fridge up
with like [__] for shakes yeah like we
could have hit our calories could have
been working out three four times a week
my problem is always eating too much oh
so if we had that [__] laying around I
would have gained way too much weight no
but if we just replace the bad boy's
drawer with like a healthy [__] yeah
that's true I'm just saying we could
have we could have turned that into like
Iron City yeah what was in the bad arm
Farm what was in the bags
what wasn't in there we always had a
full sleeves of Chips Ahoy yep every
night yeah Oreos m m peanuts brownies I
mean dude yeah it was bad all kinds of
[__] in there it's called that for a
reason we took a step towards diabetes
with what was in that drawer